bonsoir bonsoir merci ça me fait très
plaisir d'être ici ce soir pour vous
parler de ce existence même si shell
pour la plupart du monde la science
c'est très loin d'être sexy mais pour un
chercheur comme moi c'est très important
que ce qu'on fait soit jugé comme étant
sexy parce que c'est ce qui nous permet
de face qui nous passionne et d'aller
chercher de l'argent pour le faire une
une grande partie aussi de mon travail
de professeur chercheur à l'université
c'est la formation de futurs chercheurs
donc le la formation d'étudiants de
maîtrise doctorat à l'université vous en
éveillant ici à l'écran c'est monsieur
docteur maintenant la scène de nos
moeurs qui est original sud du maroc et
qui a passé les six années qu'on va
durer son doctorat avec un manteau
d'hiver sur le dos souvent demandé oui
mes amis pourquoi tu vas chercher des
étudiants aussi loin
la réponse est simple c'est que la
recherche sous les racines d'arbres
c'est vraiment beau sexy en tout cas
c'est pas mal moins sexy que d'étudier
la marque d'amérique sur le territoire
cri ou par exemple d'étudier la la
reproduction des caribous dans le grand
nord ou encore l'alimentation de la
petite nyctale en abitibi la recherche
sur les racines c'est pas sexy parce que
premièrement on voit rien donc si
c'est assez difficile pour quelqu'un de
développer sa curiosité scientifique ou
de développer des bonnes questions de
recherche qui ferait que la recherche
deviendrai sexy pour quelque chose qu'on
voit pas c'est pas sexy deuxièmement
parce que des racines savidan de la
terre et de l'eau ça finit toujours par
faire pas mal de brett fils a fait qu'à
la fin à sa journée de travail
tu te demandes toujours pour que ces
forts que j'ai pas décidé d'utiliser la
reproduction des tortues marines sur les
plages de hawaï est bon mon directeur de
thèse m'avait dit ça à la fin de l'été
où j'ai passé tout l'été à sillonner la
forêt boréale avec des roses à pompiers
autour du cou pour excaver les forêts de
30me dix années dit que si jamais tu
trouves un étudiant qui veut bien
travailler sur les racines du temps pas
très grand soin parce que c'est très
très rare
ça c'est quelque chose que j'ai compris
assez rapidement mais ce que j'ai aussi
compris c'est que
là ce que j'ai aussi compris c'est que
oui la recherche sur les racines sont
peut être sexy et c'est ce que je vais
essayer de vous démontrer ce soir avec
ma présentation que oui ça vaut la peine
de creuser et oui il faut creuser pour
comprendre la forêt les arbres mais
surtout pour comprendre comment les
arbres ont évolué les uns avec les
autres
donc cette histoire a commencé dans
l'ouest canadien où après ce qu'on a
appelé le grand déclin des forêts 30 qui
on a observé notre tout l'amérique du
nord
on a observé que les papes les mentors
moore est un peu partout comme sur de
façon inexpliquée
puis on s'est demandés c'est un
phénomène qui est assez inquiétant parce
que je sais pas si vous savez mais le
papier faux tremble c'est une espèce
d'arbre c'est l'espace qui la plus
distribuée en amérique du nord donc on
la retrouve complètement à l'aise
continent ça va jusqu'au nord au nord de
l'alaska au puis ça descend ensuite
jusqu'au mexique
c'est un phénomène qui était pas
suffisamment inquiétant pour l'ouest
américain parce que dans ce coin de la
planète
les foires et 30 sont de plus en plus
rares et en très grande valeur
économique mais aussi une grande valeur
biologique et une grande valeur
esthétique dans le paysage donc les
amércains trouve que c'est de très
belles forêts qui sont nécessaires pour
les préserver contrairement à ici ou des
fois on voit plus se trompe comme une
mauvaise herbe
donc on s'est demandé comment ça se fait
les foires et rend mujer puis étant
donné que c'est une espèce d'arbre qui
se régénère à partir de ses racines dont
vous avez un exemple si vous avez la
grande racines d'un arbre et suite à une
coupe ou alors un feu de forêt par
exemple la racine va produire plusieurs
petits dragons qui vont faire
éventuellement des arbres donc on s'est
dit bon parce que c'est une espèce qui
est très dépendante de ses racines
peut-être qu'elle s'y sont en train de
mourir c'est parce qu'ils ont un
problème avec les unes peut-être qu'une
maladie ou un champignon qui a fait que
ces racines là qui font que les enfants
sont en train de mourir
donc j'ai naïvement proposer mon
directeur de thèse mais allons voir au
lieu de se poser un paquet de spots l on
va les voir les déterrer ce qu'on a
trouvé c'est complètement à l'opposé de
ce qu'on pense et ce qu'on a trouvé
c'est que la majorité des racines
étaient vivantes et en santé malgré le
fait que la majorité des arbres étaient
morts ou en train de mourir comment ça
se fait comment ça se peut que des
racines son avis alors que les armes de
desquels elle par son sont morts parce
qu'une chose qui conte et en assure
didier bien de choses faut savoir ce que
des racines d'arbres ça fait pas de
photosynthèse donc la racine comme telle
elle peut pas se nourrir tout seul c'est
pas qu'on est un peu un arbre qui vivent
à
donc toutes les organismes vivants momar
éventuellement ses sont pas nourris
quand ils arrivent au bout de la réserve
carnet qui peuvent survivre un petit peu
plus longtemps que non mais
éventuellement si on mange pas au fini
par mourir donc comment ça se fait par
massa se peut si vous avez bien observer
vous avez vu que les arbres sont
connectés les uns avec les autres
donc vous voyez si une connexion qui
relie l'arbre son voisin une autre là
bas son voisin et on a trouvé comme ça
que la majorité des arbres étaient
reliés les uns avec les autres ce qui
permettait que si un amour et d'un
groupe
le reste la communauté où les autres
arbres pouvait supporter le système
racinaire des autres qui étaient morts
j'ai mis quelques exemples un autre
exemple ici où on voit bien que les
arbres sont très intimement reliés par
des grosses structures de bois comme ça
qui sont pratiquement est de faisable
un autre exemple si si c'est notre
espèce et le peuplier beaumier ou le
lien comme on l'appelle en abitibi et
vous voyez ces grosses racines là très
imposant qui relie comme ça les armes
les uns avec les autres
je sais pas si vous
vous avez l'habitude de voir des
représentations d'arbres schématiser
c'est vraiment l'opposé de ce qu'on
aurait également observé on observera en
masse ce design là je me dis que c'est
probablement parce que rarement des
personnes se sont donné la peine d'aller
déterrer d'aller voir ce qu'on voyait
vraiment certaines personnes les foresti
qui connaissent un peu les hommes me
diront oui mais c'est normal les essais
des peupliers s'excusera jaunards par
les racines
donc c'est normal son coin qu'ils soient
connectés mais on est fait de la
vérification en abitibi dans nos forêts
avec du pain gris ou l'épinette noire et
on a observé le même phénomène soit que
la majorité des armes encore une fois
sont reliés par leur asséner voyez cd
des liens assez forts des gros liens qui
permettent même encore une fois à des
arts vivants de maintenir des arbres des
racines d armor au laboratoire et même
sur le terrain on ait réussi à démontrer
mais à quoi ça sert ces liens restent
néerlandais arbres donc ce qu'on est
fait ici on fait une expérience où on a
planté dans des pots séparer d'eux armé
qui était quand même relié par une
ration vous voyez si on a gardé la
racine connecte rice vivante dans un
tuyau comme ça parce qu'on ait fait ce
qu'on arrose et seulement qu'un armes et
l'ont le fait sécher pendant plusieurs
mois
ce qu'on a pu observer ce qu'on a pu
mesurer ce qu'il y avait vraiment un
transfert d'eau d'un emballage de l'art
baron gérard labbe sécher qui a permis
au bout d'expérience de constater que
l'abe lequel on n'avait pas osé du tout
avait pu croire de la même façon que
l'arbre qui était arrosé
l'autre question qu'on se pose c'est
pourquoi les impressions pourquoi un
arbre dépasserait beaucoup d'énergie à
produire des l'irrationnel qui a soudé
ce dépasserait encore plus d'énergie
pour nourrir les racines d'un homme qui
est déjà mort
donc on a subi on s'est questionné sur 7
sur cette question de recherche heures
pour essayer de comprendre pourquoi on
le ferait donc vous voyez si ce qu'on à
faire dans une forêt de tremble encore
une fois c'est qu'on a coupé tous les
arbres ce qu'on a pu constater vraiment
c'est que les tous les arbres se sont
régénérés par leurs racines comme le
tremblay fait habituellement pis même
les armes en donc si vous voyez bien que
d armor comme celui ci ou comme suit
celui ci qui guident complètement de
composer complètement parti qui a pu se
régénérer
par ses racines parce que les arbres
voisins ses amis l'avaient maintenu son
système racinaire envie donc pourquoi un
arbre dépasserait de l'énergie comme ça
et
à nourrir les racines de ses voisins qui
sont déjà morts si on croit la théorie
de l'évolution
on peut passer que
oui ça coûte de l'énergie mais c'est
probablement bénéfique un certain niveau
pour l'espèce
sinon c'est en bleu survivrait pas dans
le temps et c'est effectivement ce qu'on
a constaté c'est que cette stratégie low
de maintenir les racines des arbres
voisins
ça a permis à l'espèce en fait de garder
le territoire pour la même espèce plutôt
que de faire des trous dans le paysage
pour que d'autres espèces viennent
envahir le territoire
donc si au prochain passage d'une
coupable a par exemple de feux de forêt
les spurs vont être capables assez à se
mettre d'accord les uns aux autres de
garder son territoire donc finalement ce
qu'on peut dire c'est que qu'est ce que
la recherche sur les racines nous a
démontré c'est que oui ça peut être
coûteux et ça peut être lourd en énergie
de supporter ses voisins tout pardon son
voisin mais que dans d'autres situations
ça peut aussi nous être bénéfique et que
comme pour la société humaine de se
soutenir les uns les autres finalement
ça devient bénéfice pour toute la
communauté
merci